there's one in every family so um I'm
this is one of those things I might
regret I'm diving into but I don't know
it's been on my mind I'm not so I'm
gonna give it a go anyway I'm gonna talk
about toxic fandoms specifically toxic
geek fandoms and I'm gonna talk in some
broad strokes on a lot of this and bring
up specific as in some cases but you
know this is something I don't have a
particular thing that tipped me over
into wanting to talk about this except
that is something that I've been dealing
with the various extents 400 while I
mean basically since the channel started
gaining at at a faster you know if any
more subscribes at a faster rate little
over a year ago so before I start
getting into anything there's a couple
things I want to preface first the first
thing is that every fandom and every
section of any fandom is capable of
exist of exhibiting toxic behaviors it
is not restricted to any one specific
line of thinking it's not it's not
specific to holding a certain opinion
because that is not what is toxic
ultimately what is toxic it's not what
you think
it's not the opinion that you hold it's
the way you behave based on that opinion
or to sort of paraphrase a term that
I've heard in relation to say movies and
things of that nature it's not what you
are about it's how you are about it so I
really I'm gonna try very hard to not
have this be a condemnation of
particular trains of thought or
particular opinions that I may agree or
disagree with because
I just I just want to talk about
behavior and I what I don't want this to
be is a series of me just whacking a
finger at anybody because it doesn't
help but when I say toxic fandom I mean
often times I mean much like when you
attach the word toxic to anything it
does not mean that fandom itself is
toxic but it doesn't mean that there was
this particular particular stripe of
fandom that is and I guess the first
question is where's the line at what
point does disagreeing or not liking
something start to cross over into toxic
behavior and I am going to say we're at
least for me that line is because this
is something I have to deal with I have
to deal with it in my comments section
and I do actively moderate those but
before I get down that line I also want
to kind of deal with what I feel in many
ways is the elephant in the room for
this and this is mostly because I want
to specify I'm aware of this but I'm
also not going to deal with it so what
I'm talking about there is is it is a
known phenomenon that people who hold a
specific oftentimes political view but
do not actually have a particular care
for a specific fandom will inject
themselves into that fan conversation if
they see something that they believe
they can project their political
leanings into so like again I don't mean
this to be finger waving but I need to
deal with my own experience and this is
the sort of elements that I have had to
deal with primarily where I've seen this
in a lot of not all but in a fair number
of channels that I have seen do
takedowns of things like the current
series of Doctor Who or say the new
Shira cartoon basically labeling it as
political correctness gone mad sjw
propaganda
etc a fair number of channels where I
find that sort of stuff which is the
sort of stuff I actively avoid but I did
kind of like dig a little before sitting
down to talk about this to be sure that
I felt comfortable in my impression and
I do a fair number of these actually are
devoted to that topic of basically
attacking whatever they feel holds the
views that they don't like as opposed to
actually being fans of a property and
then not liking the direction of the
property they go hey that thing that I
never cared about is doing sgw stuff I'm
gonna do I'm gonna rant about that and
you can find that stuff fairly easily
it's fairly easy to call out it actually
kind of a little bit came to mind after
I did my video on the who Tube community
because I mentioned how welcoming and
inclusive I feel that community is and a
couple of people pointed out you know
I've seen some toxic elements but then
when I looked at some of the channels
that people named they had like a
smattering of Doctor Who stuff basically
that only started up since you know or
primarily since series 11 started or the
casting of Jodie Whittaker was announced
and then all the other stuff on their
channel is similar takedowns of other
pieces of entertainment that they feel
hold an agenda that they want to ramble
about and that's not me saying that that
they don't have the right to do that
they never right to do that but what I'm
saying is when I talk about toxic fandom
I want to talk about the people who are
already fans as opposed to the people
who have an issue with something that
any given property is doing but work
didn't care about that property until
this happened and then inject themselves
into this because that is a thing that
happens and that is a thing again as
with all this that's the thing that
happens with all sides of this
I'm freely gonna admit I am more liable
to point out when people who complain
you know this is all SJW because that's
what I personally have to deal with most
of the time but I am aware that it can
come from the other side of that debate
as well but again the people who just
inject themselves into these debates but
weren't actually active parts of this
fandom before that I don't want to deal
with them at all so now that the
kind of established why is the more
divisive aggressive things why is that
dictating the conversation so much and I
think there's a number of odd things
that kind of happen in terms of people's
mentalities and there's several things
that play and it can vary from case to
case so like I get my review for
Netflix's new Shira not long ago and I
found out afterwards that there's been a
surprising amount of quote-unquote
controversy around this which surprised
the heck out of me because like if I
were to compared to say the Thundercats
the new Thundercats show that came out
that I know a lot of people weren't
happy about either or even something
like Teen Titans go I understand agree
necessarily with the fan backlash to
those sorts of new adaptations I do kind
of get it because in those cases Teen
Titans go possibly a little more validly
than Thundercats but I get where fans of
those particularly of the earlier
incarnations of those feel like they are
losing something because this goofier
sillier version of something they like
exists they aren't getting the version
that they want and so they actually feel
a loss she don't really feel like that
should be in the mix because she wrote I
mean like to compare to say he-man
he-man had its original run that people
know best and then it had a live-action
film and it had a retooling and then it
had a complete reboot and they've been
trying to get another film going since
Shira has been effectively dead since
that original show in the 80s it never
got a revisit never got a revamp never
got a reboot
so effectively Shira hasn't existed
other than as a cultural artifact since
the 80s so I don't think or at least it
shouldn't be a case of Oh while we're
losing the version we could have
had when this reboot happened that
shouldn't be a play because there was no
other version for you to say you wanted
instead I mean even with Thundercats
there was the the previous reboot
attempt that didn't you know move
forward or last as long as the fans
would have liked but it but they could
go oh but we couldn't they could have
kept trying that and instead we've got
this goofy Thundercats war thing and
again Teen Titans very much a similar
thing so if it's not a case of a fandom
losing something and then that's another
element that like you could consider to
be in play with some of the outcry
against some of the things Marvel did in
the last few years in terms of having
new people taking up the mantle of Iron
Man MS Marvel The Incredible Hulk Thor
and a few others Wolverine
but I mean firstly I think in a lot of
cases people who I always kind of felt
those concerns were over exaggerated
because I don't I don't know why anyone
thought those were gonna be permanent
changes because Marvel's never really
gone in for the legacy hero thing on a
long-term basis not like DC used to so
these sorts of shake ups with Marvel are
pretty much always temporary and they're
usually designed to be but there would
have been and there is a certain
validity to say I now don't have the
hero I want and love because you have
this other character being this hero
again the level that people take it to
can be an issue but I at least get that
but like like I said what something like
she wrote that's weird
to me that because that shouldn't be in
the mix so why are there things like
that where that happens and I think
where it starts to really crossover from
you know being just a frustrated fan
which I often am many things that I love
I'm highly frustrated with I'm really
frustrated with Star Wars I'm really
frustrated with Harry Potter right now
on occasion I can be frustrated with
Doctor Who you know I I love these
things but they irritate me sometimes
but where it crosses over from
frustration to something a little bit
more
is I think the point at which it becomes
not about you being upset that you lost
something but you start to become angry
that someone who isn't you gained
something and sort of the way it's been
weaponized is that if a group that for
whatever reason you've decided you don't
like you know some kind of demographic
if you see what you feel is that
demographic getting something that they
get to enjoy rather than you getting
something like there can be a again a
frustration with that but that's where I
think it starts to cross over to
toxicity where the anger isn't it's when
the anger isn't rooted in oh I don't get
to have the thing I like but instead
becomes why do they get a nice thing I
hate them for that and that honestly I
think that is the line for toxic fandom
is the point at which it crosses over
from well first of all hate is a strong
emotion it's a stronger word and it's
when I try to not use and not because
I'm like afraid of the word hate but
like it's supposed to be a potent thing
and I think people overuse it and if
they truly are feeling that level of
hate with things that you know as much
as some people claim to be that that
concerns me on a different level but you
know like I don't think it's toxic to
say I hate what has happened to Star
Wars under Kathleen Kennedy's watch I do
think it starts at toxic to say I hate
Kathleen Kennedy when you start
directing your anger away from the
abstract away from the individual pieces
of art the way from away from the
franchise and at people when you start
targeting your anger at people be it
the creators be it critics
who don't agree with your assessment of
a piece of art be it fans who are happy
with something that you're unhappy with
when you start directing your anger at
individuals real people buy and true
nouveau in I mean I can get angry I can
get angry and ranty but I tried very
very hard to direct that at the work and
not the people and even when I express
my frustration at the people I try and
really have it be over this specific
narrative thing that they did and not go
down the path of you're a terrible
person I hate you because I don't want
to hate somebody for making a piece of
art I didn't like and I think there's
also a tendency to really over demonize
certain fundamental political views that
we don't agree with and that kind of all
gets rolled into this as well so and
again I think ultimately that should be
coming down to execution rather than
concept so when people who have not even
seen something like Shira are denouncing
it because they believe it feeds into a
left-leaning political philosophy and
they're condemning it for that without
even considering how those ideas are
expressed the qualities of the piece of
art that has those concepts behind it
that's wealth at best that's frustrating
so like for me I love the movie 300 I
think it's a fantastic movie I
fundamentally disagree with a lot of the
philosophical underpinnings of that
movie and I certainly do not agree with
the major philosophies of the hero
characters but it's still a great movie
visually astonishing it's really
phenomenally paced it's well acted it's
engaging as heck the characters are
charismatic it's a great movie that has
underpinnings that I don't agree with
but again it's not what it's about it's
how it is about it and I would and if I
didn't like 300 I would I like to think
at least I would not like it because it
wasn't a well-made film not because it
espoused philosophical ideas that I
disagree with we've drawn so many hard
lines lately where I'm on this side
you're on that side and anything I see
over there on that side of this line
that's the worst and there is no good
that can come from anything on that side
it's kind of the approach that people
tend to take but here's where I want to
end on a slightly nah hopefuls not the
right word reassuring note for all that
I'm saying and all that I deal with I do
still believe very firmly and every
thing that I see every time I actually
stop and think and look and analyze
carefully backs this up these elements
that I'm talking about these fans that
exhibit toxic behaviors they are very
loud they are very good at driving the
conversation they're also the minority
they disproportionately take up an
irritatingly large amount of the
conversation because of how loud they
are they become very difficult to ignore
but they are not the majority I feel
incredibly confident in saying that
because every time I have actually like
really basically run the numbers and and
it's it's easy to lose sight especially
in social media because I think it's a
very human thing where you know you put
something out there be it a tweet a
video what have you a hundred people say
they really like it one person says it's
craft you put more weight in
that because I think a lot of us is and
unless you have like a bulletproof ego a
lot of us assume there's more honesty
and criticism than compliment but if you
actually run the numbers more often than
not or and I can't say this is the
experience for everybody but this is my
experience when I look at the numbers
when I compare how many really horrible
comments I have to delete off something
like Star Wars video or or you know when
I talk about lgbtq+ representation or
things of that nature as much as I hate
having to do that and it pains me every
single time I have to delete a comment
or block somebody off the channel I also
can reassure myself this is not most
people and it's easy to lose sight of
that because most people don't make
waves
most people have more measured feelings
and unfortunately it's oftentimes hard
to hear the voice going well you know
there's good and there's bad to be had
here in the middle of a shouting match
between the extremes the middle ground
gets drowned out even though the middle
ground is the majority I I do very
sincerely believe that when it comes to
most of these things and I think that's
the thing that we really need to try and
keep sight of the Toxic fan elements
well first of all the other thing I'll
add they're not new they haven't been
created by the internet by reddit by
fortune by whatever these have simply
given them a platform for them to come
together as a more unified force but I
can think back to my own childhood I
think in grade school of of slightly
older you know maybe by only four or
five years but slightly older Star Wars
fans giving massive grief to
younger Star Wars fans because those
younger Star Wars fans liked the Ewok
cartoon i I don't think this has been
created by the technology we have the
technology we have simply allows these
people to have a megaphone but again we
have to remind ourselves that these
people are new we've been dealing with
them forever and just because they're
shouting louder does not mean that we
have to give them the attention that
they want I'm not gonna go so far as to
claim if we ignore them they'll go away
no they won't
they never will but we can you know what
we actually can do we can address their
argue their arguments their toxicity
even without engaging them directly we
can agree amongst each other yeah that
thing that happened over there when this
group of people drove an actor from a
film off of social media through a
concentrated harassment and threat
campaign yeah that was awful wasn't it
we don't actually need to engage them
and go you're terrible for doing that
because engaging them is what they want
we don't have to we can talk about it we
can talk about what's going on and we
can go yeah we're not gonna be that we
don't actually have to engage and I
think I will wrap up on that note so the
very loaded topic of toxic fandoms what
are your thoughts on this I know there's
a bit of a divisive topic be respectful
and I like I said I tried very hard to
not name names so please don't let the
comment section devolve into a list of
who you think the worst offenders are I
I don't care let's talk about the
element we don't have to name names we
can still have the conversation
regardless but whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
you can do because there's buttons and
there's links including a link to my
patreon if you feel like lending me your
support in that fashion if you don't
don't worry about
otherwise you can check out too if you
don't want to look at those don't have
to worry about that either because at
the end of the day folks you are the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]